hello and welcome i'm james murphy and today
we're going to be testing to see how fast is
python's built-in sort well i've already got
the code here let's just uncomment it you see
i make a list i shuffle it up and then i time
how long it takes to sort it and print it out
so let's see how long it takes... well there you
go 207 microseconds end of the video right? well
no. obviously there are a ton of things wrong
with the way that i tried to profile this.
for one i'm recording the video at
the same time that i ran the test
and that's definitely going to affect the speed
if i want to measure the performance of sort in
a more reliable way, better than this quick
and dirty implementation, then i'm going to
have to put a little bit more thought into it.
so for starters i've listed out here some of
the common things that affect the performance
of a sort these first four are obvious things,
the performance can also depend on less obvious
things like the order that you run the tests in.
this is a very common trap that people fall into
if you're not familiar with performance testing
consider this case for example. i have two
functions function and function 2 and i wanna see
which one is faster so i write the most obvious
thing i just profile them one at a time i run it
see how much time it took and then i run
the second one and see how much time it took
well let's do it so in this case we can see 671
versus 417 so it looks like function 2 is better
right well just to be sure let's run it again
okay this time it was about 500 versus 300 so the
numbers were a little bit different but it still
definitely looks like the second one is better
okay so what are these two functions well the
first one i was just converting a range of 10
000 integers to a list and the second function
was... oh well it's exactly the same function so
you can see that it's not function one or function
two that's slower it's whichever one ran first is
the slower one and in addition to all these things
of course it matters what else is running on your
machine at the same time and all kinds of wild
things can affect the performance. that's why
performance testing is actually a very very subtle
and tricky field what i'm going to show you here
today of course is only going to be applicable
for my computer my operating system my version
of python and everything else that's specific
to just my machine but the source code is on the
github page so if you want to see how fast your
sort is then feel free to run the code yourself.
okay so let's get started so the first thing
that i'm going to define is a sorting test
case this specifies everything that you need
to run a single test for a single size one time
then you can run the test as many times as you
want to get better data about your test case.
the size here is meant to represent the size of
the list that you're going to be sorting. the seed
allows me to ensure that i have a reproducible
test case every time. this data maker is another
class that we're defining essentially its job
is to take in the size and seed and give you
some data so part of a test case is you need to
generate some data and then sort it so the data
maker tells you how to generate the data and then
the sort keyword arguments tell you what arguments
you pass to the sort. finally this field of
times is where we store the results of our
runs of the test so let's take a look at this
data maker class well in actuality there's
not much in data maker it is an abstract base
class it's essentially defining an interface.
all i'm saying is that anything that claims
to be a data maker needs to have a make method
it needs to take in the size and the seed and
produce a list of data that we're going to sort.
the compatible keys and compatible sort keyword
arguments functions here are not really important
at this stage they're essentially just saying
for this type of data maker what kind of things
can you call the sort function with so what is an
example of a data maker? well the simplest thing
is how about random integers so you can see an
implementation of a data maker is very simple all
i do is specify this make function i use the numpy
seed function to see the numpy random generator
and then i use numpy random to generate random
integers between you know some low and high of
the given size and then i convert that to a list
so this would be your typical most common sorting
case you're just sorting integers for this data
maker it's a sorted uniform maker meaning i start
by getting uniform ints and then i sort them so
this is going to be useful for testing how long
does sort take on data that's already sorted, and
then you could have something like nearly sorted
which is i start out with something sorted and
then make 10 random swaps in it, does that affect
things? i don't know we'll find out. the rest of
these are just slight variations on the same idea
with different types or different you know
extra parameters so uniformly distributed
floats between zero and one same thing as
the previous but sorting them what if i
generate using a gaussian distribution or normal
distribution instead of a uniform distribution
this maker looks at the case where there aren't
that many choices of what the answer could be
so you could see my low here is 0 and the high of
32 so there's only 33 choices of possible answer
and then these two just make random strings or
sorted random strings finally for data makers
i've defined a class here two ints and a string
this is meant as a stand-in in your code you have
defined some classes and for whatever reason
you don't want them to be just you know a
tuple or something it's a real class pretend
that it has extra methods and it does things
and it's only data members are x y and s so
how long does it take to sort a class that has
a you know built in less than operator then this
maker just makes random int random randomint and
then random strings and then plops them into the
two ints and a string class and returns a list of
those so this one is the same as the previous one
except instead of storing x y and s in this class
two instead of string we're going to store it just
in a tuple and now we're back down to the sorting
test case so you can see now what this is we have
our size, seed, data maker so this is going to be
something like our uniform int maker which is
going to tell us okay given this size and seed
go ahead and make me some data then what does the
run do? well it just times how long does it take
to sort so it does the timing and then appends
the time to the end of the times list the next
function i want to look at is this make all test
cases basically it takes in a list of sizes seeds
and data makers that you want to test and then
it creates all the test cases and then puts them
in a big list of test cases. once i have my big
list of test cases i pass it to this function run
tests n times which actually does something very
important. so in order to counteract the problem
that we saw at the beginning where the order that
we run the tests in affects the answer to the you
know performance test in order to counteract
that we're actually going to shuffle our tests
so we're going to shuffle them and then run all
of them and then shuffle them and then run all of
them and so on and so forth this many times once
i run all my tests then i'm going to convert them
to a pandas data frame for easy processing and
plotting and then i will make a plot out of it so
let's see how it's all put together in main first
off we have this recompute results if this is true
that means you want to actually run all the tests
and once you run the test it's actually going to
save it to a file save the results to a file so
that if you just want to show the plot again and
not rerun all the tests again you can just set
this to false and then rerun it this parameter
just lets you choose whether or not you also
want to show the reverse sorts in the same plot
then here are the important things so what sizes
are we going to be testing well range 1024 so the
numbers zero to 1023 and what seeds am i using
well zero through nine and then finally trials
is the number of times that i'm going to run
every single test case so same seed same size
i'm going to run every single one 20 times then
here i have my list of data makers and you can
see i just make an instance of each of those
maker classes i'm just going to test everything
so you can see if we want to
recompute the results then we
make all the test cases run them end
times convert them to a data frame
and then pickle them to a file if we don't want
to recompute things then we hit this else and
just read the existing file and then filter out
the data makers that we're not interested in
so of course i can't run this code while i'm
recording so i'm going to go ahead and do that
offline and then show you the results that i got
which are then going to be saved into this file.
the first thing that i notice is that there are
definitely clumps of twos so you can see for each
of these lines there's essentially two colors and
that's because the reverse sort and the forward
sword are taking essentially the same time okay so
let's comment out these and just look at the ints
so the first thing that i notice is
what are these down at the very bottom
so if i click on these you can see that these
sorted ones are the ones down at the bottom
so python is definitely doing something that's a
lot faster for already sorted arrays i also notice
that the reverse sort is always slightly above the
normal sort that kind of makes sense because to
do a reverse sort you just reverse sort and then
reverse or that's how python does it anyway okay
let's get rid of the sorted ones and the reversed
ones so the difference between these three curves
is essentially due to the distribution so this
pink one is the uniform the blue one is the one
that was uniform but there were only a few choices
so the blue one had a lot of overlaps and then the
green one was nearly sorted so it wasn't as fast
as the ones that were already sorted but it does
seem to be quite a bit faster than the ones that
aren't sorted so here are the floats and again we
see that the reverse ones are pretty similar to
the non-reversed ones so let me just hide those
and again we see that the already sorted
one is the fastest one by a large margin
and then the difference between these two is
whether it was a uniformly distributed float
or a normally distributed gaussian distribution
so we can see that whether it's uniform or normal
makes essentially no difference for floats
let's move on to strings once again the
sorted ones are much faster and reverse
sorting a sorted collection of strings
is doing significantly worse than the sorted
version but significantly better than just random
however just for random strings reverse sorting
is just about the same as normal sorting
all right let's finally go to two ints and a
string and we see something very surprising
for this one well first let me note unsurprisingly
sorting this struct took quite a bit longer than
sorting just an integer but the surprising thing
is here look at the difference between sorting
a class versus sorting a tuple that contains the
same information as the class. the reverse sorting
is essentially the same as the forward sorting
now we just see the difference this blue line
is trying to sort a list of elements of
a class and the green line is sorting
the same exact elements but just stored
in a tuple that's a huge difference.
yeah so this is like 1/10 the time scale so
that's an interesting find all. right let me
just put the picture back up where i'm not going
to show any of the reverse plots and i'm not going
to show any of the sorted things just so we can
get one final glimpse at the picture of how long
it takes to sort. so this is kind of the final
picture that you can take away from this process
but i just want to reiterate some of the lessons
that we've learned through exploring this data.
so the final answer to the question how fast
is python's built in sort is it depends. it
depends on how much you're sorting what type
of data what the parameters of the sort are
what's the distribution of the data and all
kinds of different other things completely
unrelated to the data so there's no real one
answer of course the real point of this video
is that if you want to measure performance and
you want a reliable answer you need to test
it yourself on your own hardware in a production
setting where you're going to be using it you need
to control as many of these different variables
as you can and make them as realistic as possible
so sorry if the title was clickbait. as always
thanks for watching don't forget if you liked the
video leave a like and if you especially liked the
video consider subscribing see you in the next one